[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to I
really shouldn't have reviewed the emoji
movie because that just opened up the
floodgates for more current crap I mean
I know awhile ago I said not everything
ever viewed had to be nostalgic but I do
like it to have some served nostalgic
time after the emoji movie though
everyone sent me requests to review
another current abomination only this
one was actually a big hit led to a
spin-off show and even got nominated for
Best Animated picture that means it's
not only bad but considering its
audience it's embarrassingly bad
boss baby got a lot of people rolling
their eyes at the trailer the same way
the emoji movie did but somehow I made a
big splash in a diaper filled a
phoned-in urine even the idea of a baby
acting adults seem old with cartoons and
a lot of alan smith these later work but
somehow this grabbed a lot of people
despite a ton of negative feedback is it
the confusing black hole of dumb so many
have declared it to be there's only one
way to know for sure
sadly let's take a look at what
generations from now will be embarrassed
by with what we're currently embarrassed
by this is boss baby the film opens in
the Congo well I will use somebody money
as it turns out our main character Tim
is having a jungle fantasy as the older
version of himself played by Tobey
Maguire explains you see I was seven
years old and back then you relied on
your imagination if somebody told you I
was just your average ordinary guy not a
care in the world or that I'm Michael
Cera and Molly's game somebody lied it's
go time
tim has a lot of fantasies about him and
his folks too many fantasies honestly
what the hell's even going on right now
[Music]
even for kids fantasy this this is a
little weird the parents say he might be
getting a baby brother which gets into
thinking where babies come from
we immediately cut to where this movie
came from as the credits from storks
Rolo I mean no this is stories this is
totally storks it looks like any baby
that laughs I getting tickled is given a
family and any baby that doesn't is
thrown into management Christ I hope
your tummy is sensitive because it
describes the fate of your future is
this a commentary on stupid or just a
stupid commentary Tim's baby brother
steps out of a taxi suit and all and
surprises it look who's here I had a
million questions
you win every human being watching this
kid he set up this office right smack
dab in the middle of the house he
conducted meetings lots and lots of
meetings so I guess the ideas this is
all toll from Tim's point of view I
think so his quote meetings are just him
crying and the parents coming to his aid
and he's not literally in a suit
a suit I know is thank you or maybe he
is so wait she was clearly pregnant
earlier but he arrives in a taxi why do
I feel like that's only the beginning of
my questions Tim makes a big discovery
though when he sees that his brother now
boys by Alec Baldwin is a pompous angry
whiny psychopath say with me I think his
old one is playing this less as a
comedic character and more is it
disturbed even frightening presents I've
picked that bone enough his Trump is
really good I can't tell how
intentionally scary he's supposed to be
though does his menacing delivery add to
the comedy of it coming from a baby or
does that just make everything even more
unsettling there's no place for Tim just
imagine the dialogue from this movie
coming from a more menacing role like
The Aviator do the math kid there's only
so much love to go around the numbers
just don't add up there's not enough
love for the two of us to keep quiet
stay out of my way or there's gonna be
cutbacks kinda creepy isn't it Tim
naturally becomes afraid of the suddenly
talking baby destined to destroy his
life as he wakes up the next morning -
on here I thought the most your
pants were the baby and the Sun was from
Teletubbies given me two options on this
Tim starts talking to his alarm clock
which again leans towards him imagining
all this but why do his fantasies change
so much then sometimes there's a style
sometimes there isn't and we can't
figure out what's real and what's not
like is the damn baby wearing a suit and
the damn baby talk it makes it harder to
understand the comedy and more
importantly it creates a damn ass weird
tone that nobody can get you know the
kid playing Tim is the grandson of Ralph
Bakshi I'm starting to think a bloody
riot of pigs and closes in our
not-too-distant future
what really surprised you at this point
he answers this fantasy realm which
again we're not sure if we're always in
or not to try and get proof that the
baby is talking to show his folks hey
screw the folks get us proof if he's
talking or not I have no idea what's
going on
now my pants were yellow and I have no
idea what's going on
it looks like the parents are having a
playdate with other kids that boss baby
which I'm just now realizing is his
actual name parents can be such abstract
dicks uses this as a meaning for other
talking babies babies aren't getting as
much love as we used to y know we've
been making films like this I'd want to
slap a baby after watching behold our
mortal enemy no so bad enough it's
dealing from other movies it'll be at
the strangest parts of them now they
have to rip off movies that weren't even
arguably movies it looks like puppy Co a
competitor for baby Co which if
everybody knows about why are the babies
pretending not to talk why am i thinking
I should really stop that he's launching
a new puppy which the baby see is a
threat and if this new puppy is this
cute as we fear it could put the baby
business out of business baby so the
human race will stop because we're gonna
start making love to puppies I didn't
think that was a question boss baby
would ask me today but I'm not seeing
any other direction is pointing me in
but they see Tim recorded their
conversation and they try to get it from
him so oh look the kids are finally
getting along that's nice this is all a
fantasy why are we cutting from Tim's
point of view suddenly we've never done
before if Tim is telling this story is
he just saying and then suddenly in
reality this is what was going on it
wasn't really a big action sequence to
put the baby was still wearing a suit
the baby was still wearing a goddamn
suit this whole film is like a Zen
riddle of idiocy if you solve it you
don't become enlightened you just become
Dumber boss baby is tossed outside only
to end up in his office this movie cares
so little even they draw attention to
that inconsistency hand over the tape
Timmy what do we care we know Oscar
voters never watch the movies they
nominate and Timmy gets strangely
murderous
oh and I almost launched a baby into a
car but still my crew Tim is of course
grounded which he sees as a prison but
boss baby interrupts his fantasy because
the boss baby is in the real world where
they named their kids boss baby and he
has a chat with him
I'm on a mission from above oh here the
baby Jesus yes I'm the baby Jesus this
movie's dumb it's not that dumb no take
this I want you to suck it no it's for
you to suck okay for a kid's movie these
are way too many variations of Alec
Baldwin using the word suck I don't know
it's not where it's been that's where
we'll take you well that just sounds
like his wedding proposal don't you want
to know where babies really come from so
he sucks it and has taken to where
babies apparently really come from this
is where babies come from where'd you
think the Cabbage Patch magic fairies
vaginas actually they kind of a dress
that my parents told me that oh no it's
disgusting yeah it didn't sound right to
me either
that's why I created this fantasy of
denial that's my most probable movie
fairy so boss baby explains that he has
to find out what this new puppy is so he
can get promoted but if not he'll be
given a formula that turns him into a
normal baby keeping him there forever I
will help you but just to get rid of you
deal here's to never seeing you again
hey it's what every parent said after
watching this stinkhole
[Applause]
[Music]
so Tim agrees to help boss baby find out
info on this new puppy it just so
happens that's where his parents work
and it also just so happens it's bring
your kid to work day you want to get a
picture with puppy Co Pete I don't think
it's official whoever directed this
should not have children or pets look
it's how they make their Netflix Show
spin-off nah they be covered in much
more they dress boss baby like a
puppy and sneak him through the puppy
door again I feel like that's just an
average encounter for Alec Baldwin they
find the file on the puppy and switch it
out obviously parenting UHF and the
mouse trap is set
literally it's its mousetrap hey I can't
get that thing past the marble slide how
did all of this go off without a hitch
they're confronted by puppy COEs own
heir played by Steve Buscemi named
Francis Francis again there's people in
the boss baby in this nothing matters
and he reveals he was one of the big
guns at babyco he explains how he was
cast out though and now his new puppy
creation that never ages will put them
out of business
all he needs is the secret formula that
keeps babies young you brought me the
very thing I needed to destroy baby core
hey remember when this movie started
with where do babies come from who are
you get its out Jim your parents I'm
taking them both with me to Las Vegas
they never leave us alone except for
this moment of them leaving us alone the
parents are duped into going with
Francis Francis well as henchmen make
sure the kids don't escape they do
escape though and call for backup
[Applause]
this movie strangely has more baby abuse
than I was expecting which I wouldn't
mind except it never ends the film but
it's too late as their parents are taken
away wait I thought we were getting
close to the end here for you baby core
is going to go out of business
you even know it's like to be part of a
family damn it I thought this was the
third act climax it turns out it's a
third act I don't like you part I wish
I'd never met you I wish you'd never
been born
yeah you got me movie I guess they're
just gonna hate each other from here on
out no character revelations here it's
just a half hour of sulking
oh wait that's freaking Mei he calls Tim
on the white phone to say sorry
despite literally being across from him
because like any kids they can't do
anything without their phones and
another impersonator gives them an idea
for how to get to Vegas to save their
folks don't know we just film I wouldn't
be shocked if it just was Elvis
anything's got to impossible nobody sue
doesn't like if I go sue and head over
there we go loose we goo is a more
convincing Elvis than you what's the
matter Templeton mm my parents always
hold my hand during takeoff all this
stuff is fine but taking off on a plane
that that I need my handheld four creepy
Baldwin baby obliges and they land in
Vegas and make it to the convention
center a brand new puppy in every
continent we're going to take over the
world one heart at a time
that sounds intimidatingly adorable the
forever puppy
[Music]
[Applause]
notice how we're ly sick this movie is
Mommy Dearest has more compassion than
half these parents Francis Francis locks
the parents up and puts them in a rocket
to drop puppies all over the world is it
sad to see this movie so strange this
isn't sounding like a crazy plan anymore
they released the puppies but boss baby
starts turning into a real baby and Tim
has to somehow convince him to jump into
his arms yeah eat your heart out ending
of cocoa Tim gets him down missing the
rocket and returns to his normal self
boss baby gets promoted but of course is
unhappy
so Tim offers him a job as his baby
brother which he of course agrees to and
is dropped off via cab again I compared
this distorts that was a documentary
compared to this film oh and here's
their way around everything it's a story
he's telling his daughter well sweetie
that's how I remember it
I hope it in no way questions everything
everyone everywhere her baby sibling
seems to be born and not since Carrie
has both a confusing and haunting twist
ended a film
God Christ I have no idea what I just
watched the big problem with this film
is if it was all a fantasy there's no
real reason to be invested because we
have no concept of its reality the world
keeps changing but not in a stable way
we can all latch onto and therefore
can't really enjoy with that said it is
dumb but it is so really dumb
at least it's balls to the wall insane
as to have your run-of-the-mill boring
bad it still got good animation energy
and even though I have hearer there but
it isn't smart enough to create a
concrete world and it isn't dumb enough
just to be mindless humor it's just
awkward mostly harmless I guess but
still awkward I think yes the audience
who wanted to see this just wanted to
see Alec Baldwin as a cartoon baby do
weird cartoon baby things if you're the
kind of weirdo who wanted to see that
and I guess there must be a lot of you
that guess this film is fine but anyone
looking for clever entertainment or
again a film worthy of an Oscar
nomination is gonna find a massive load
worth changing that my nostalgia critic
and what's that
[Music]
[Applause]
are you the baby Jesus yes I'm the baby
Jesus
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out in this week we are doing
children international since 1936
children international has worked to
improve the lives of children around the
world who live in desperate poverty
their goal is to help them become
healthy educated and self-reliant adults
through one-on-one sponsorship among the
regular benefits they provide our health
and dental care educational assistance
nutritional support and a youth program
designed to broaden their horizons and
help them become leaders in their own
communities like the world changers that
support them they are focused on making
a long-term impact by helping kids all
over the world they have a bold vision
of graduating healthy educated empowered
and employed young adults from their
programs so they can achieve the goal of
breaking the cycle of poverty if you
look at their site in their YouTube page
you can see all the different ways they
help all the various children providing
them the opportunities they rightfully
deserve
click on the link and start your journey
to helping a child become everything he
or she can be
[Music]
you